una cinta que despierta el paladar y la
crisis de un maestro del cine
irrumpieron en la competencia del
festival de cannes
[Música]
dos de los mejores actores que tiene
Francia se reunieron en una película que
habla de gastronomía a la francesa de
una Gmail y Juliette protagoniza La
pasión de buffong el romance entre ollas
y vapores entre un fino gourmet y su
cocinera la cinta de época está dirigida
por el Franco vietnamita trans ancunca
que ya había abordado el tema de la
cocina en el olor de la papaya verde que
fue premiada con el Oscar esta vez el
espectador asiste a la preparación de
platos exquisitos en una borgoña donde
se cocina A fuego lento este romance
plagado de sabores
[Música]
el maestro italiano Nani moretti dirige
e interpreta su nueva película y el sol
de laberire El Sol del futuro cuenta la
historia de Giovanni un cineasta al
borde de la depresión que debe lidiar
con miles de problemas su filmación es
un desastre es un matrimonio está en
crisis su hija se enamora de un hombre
mayor y su productor francés está en la
quiebra música
te amo martins corsés
[Aplausos]
cuesta
política
de la política
justo en fin de amor
se propone entonces Conducir a su
familia su trabajo y su propia vida hace
un Porvenir luminoso la película incluye
una escena de Antología entre Giovanni y
los productores de Netflix y el sol de
la avenida es una comedia de la
nostalgia una carta de amor de moretti
al buen cine a Roma y a una época que
Quizás esté desapareciendo con la
llegada de nuevas referencias
[Música]